yes
here we are happy happy monday everyone
or as kat likes to call it iv drip day
cause you know her weekends are a little
rough so
this show is doing great and i know this
because i actually read the mail well my
young assistant clive reads them to me
as i lay in my hammock and he feeds me
grapes
he actually shoots them at me
quite a talent and a lot of the mail
says greg this show is doing great
also dude you've really been working out
and wow it's like you get taller every
day
signed neil patrick harris
but i get a few complaints a lot about
not enough camera shots of cat's feet
i forgot i gave varney my email
but um but mostly it's about swearing we
swear too much on the show and i agree
swearing can get an easy laugh and it
feels good but i don't like it when we
overdo it
so why am i saying this
well because we're
sorry
there's no other word to describe the
current situation we are in
think about it as we criminalize
parenting we decriminalize criminals as
we target people trying to protect their
kids we protect those trying to target
us
we're living in a time where we play
catch and release with deranged
criminals picking them up
and then tossing them back into the
general population like a fisherman
releasing an underweight bass
it's now a game of russian roulette the
government's the gun the bullet is the
criminal and you're the target meanwhile
all the secure libs sit in their safe
beds watching squid game on netflix a
drama from south korea where people are
randomly killed in a series of
children's games you know think hide and
go seek with machetes i enjoyed the
first episode but then i was done
because i didn't need to watch it i can
just walk outside and see it for real on
my streets
jermaine foster a sick maniac had just
allegedly robbed one woman on saturday
then knocked another woman to the ground
maria ambrosio a 58-year-old cancer
nurse she fell suffered a mortal head
wound and died a day later
this occurred in the afternoon in times
square you know the only time decent
people will venture there it was once
the number one tourist capital but now
it's squid game everyone there is either
a criminal a victim or wearing an elmo
costume
but of course here comes the second part
of the story like clockwork the fiend
had been arrested before but was
released so tell me again how racist the
justice system is
maybe to middle-aged filipino women the
perp was nailed on a groping charge and
like most other heinous thugs the
victims were women
this story gets repeated more often than
seinfeld
if he'd been in jail and received the
mental health treatment that we pay for
this wouldn't have happened you know
like when a republican was mayor
but did you know the current mayor's
wife runs an 800 million dollar program
designed to help the mentally ill people
it's only helped two so far the mayor
and his wife
there's more nuts on the streets now
than after an explosion at the planters
factory 800 million dollars no one knows
where the money went i think patio
furniture and weed
meanwhile the mayor's son gets
chauffeured by actual detectives to and
from the drug store
makes sense de blasio doesn't want his
son to be a victim of the crime wave
he's responsible for
this as attorney general merrick garland
directs the fbi to investigate parents
as domestic terror threats
yet flat earthers have more evidence in
support of its claims as real homicide
rates skyrocket he's focusing on claims
of harassment against school boards yeah
he's right you've seen all those videos
of parents following teachers into
bathrooms with their cell phones
screaming at school board members while
they're trying to have a quiet dinner in
a restaurant
going to people's homes enchanting with
bull horns in the middle of the night
oh wait that's his team
so let's imagine where this might end up
what are you in for
i murdered a guy how about you dog oh i
uh asked a question about masks at a
school board meeting
all right inmate number two back to the
del ousing state what about my baby
he'll raise him
he murdered people just one
are better than new yorker cartoons so
perhaps it's a game of deflection create
mass hysteria from a fake problem to
distract from the real problems but it's
hard to get distracted from your stolen
car closed business and knife wound but
people keep dying from black teens in
chicago to asian women in manhattan and
they don't matter because their
suffering serves no political purpose
those black lives don't matter to black
lives matter so as real criminals roam
free in the streets like moose in alaska
and parents of all colors get demonized
for caring about their kids education
what are you left with an activist
government creating activist parents for
the surest way to red pill hundreds of
millions of americans is to call them
terrorists and the second surest way is
to protect the thugs as you do that
put all of this put all of us in harm's
way now the tide turns a red tide if you
will and like a red tide small
anti-government activist groups are
going to come to the surface and bloom
we've seen movements come and go perot
back in the 90s the tea party black
lives matter line dancing
it's time
for a parents movement that stands up to
this bowel movement we call a government
safe streets and good schools are a
popular idea no matter what news channel
you watch and why pay taxes to a
government that chooses the side that
victimizes you it's like continuing to
give the schoolyard bully your lunch
money day after day how can you respect
a government that sees you as a bigger
threat than al qaeda while citizens get
murdered in broad daylight it's time for
a new black lives matter call it all
lives matter
oh but that's racist greg
and herself
sorry
i'm sorry that i swore and i apologize
for any future swearing but it's time we
gave
because if we don't we won't have any
left to give
love
tonight's guess
when she says tickets to the gun show
she means her biceps and her guns fox
news contributed laura trump
he's got a porn star's name and a lego
figure's hair radio and podcast host
buck sexton
the fire department no longer responds
when this cat gets stuck in a tree fox
news contributor catch him
and he's strong enough to beat you in
wrestling and smart enough to correct
your spelling my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world television champion tyrus
so lara number one i apologize for being
coarse in front of you i'm i'm highly
offended i'm actually gonna go well
before you go why don't you gloat a
little bit because you have left new
york yes you are gone but this is not
just new york this is happening in a lot
of cities yeah well and you see why i
mean you just laid out the foundation
for the reason that so many people have
left new york have left california
people are using losing congressional
candidates in
congressional seats in
states across the country because people
don't want to live like this
you said it exactly right you want safe
streets you want good schools for your
kids and if you don't have that why
would you stay in a place and people
aren't and i am proudly a florida
resident now
i come back from time to time just to do
gutfeld obviously because it's the
greatest show on late night tv thank you
i think you should have stopped at the
greatest show on tv on tv period yes
except um but but truly it's so sad to
see what has happened to cities like new
york this used to be one of the great
cities in the world and and gosh i hope
it comes back but it doesn't look like
we're on that trajectory right yeah
someone of course buck they'll say but
we've got great restaurants and great
broadway shows and you really can't say
that anymore because the red a lot of
the restaurants aren't open i have a
better question
why because you're you're smart
ish yeah yeah iq about 170 maybe 75.
175. why can't we stop catch and release
and why aren't the politicians in these
cities do any doing anything about this
oh boy there's so many things people
keep focusing on defund the police which
is horrible and now they're actually
refunding police in cities like austin
where they cut the budget by a hundred
plus million and guess what they had
their highest every year of murders i
mean this is true in cities across the
country but it's prosecutors offices too
i have friends in the new york city
district attorney's office and they
won't prosecute more minor crimes
because they know that they're getting
pressure from above the political winds
have changed so much that they're not
allowed to really enforce a lot of these
laws this is why if you go to the dwayne
reed that's on the corner i live right
around here everything is in plastic you
can't actually get if you want to get
four different things you have to press
the little button and then the tired
annoyed employee has to come and open it
up for you slowly i mean i go to work
every day and and tape a tv show next to
what is one of those homeless shelters
that's actually a hotel that all the
folks here are paying taxes are paying
for and it is out in front of me it's
like a refugee camp people are cooking
food they're smoking weed there's
open-air heroin usage you've been
walking around yeah this is i'm not
telling you you're not
no
i mean no
don't jump to like some damning
conclusions just yet this sounds like a
hell of a time there is some loud music
played that is that is the thing i think
there i think there's a certain coziness
between these hotels and the politicians
they're those hotels are full and
they're getting the full price i bet of
course all the usual rules the quality
of life stuff the broken windows doesn't
matter none of that none of that stuff
matters right now because once you stop
enforcing some of it i mean there are
mad max style drag races with all
illegal vehicles and they actually look
like it's out of mad max the atvs they
got like spikes on the side and they
won't do anything about it i've seen
that on a sidewalk when they're going up
sidewalks on atv that was me you should
have gotten out of the way that's that's
true yes i remember you were shirtless
no cats this is the biggest crime
increase in my lifetime and granted i'm
only 35.
but still it's very dramatic and as a
woman
how do you feel about this
that's a really generic question i am a
woman
and i feel
in this essay i will um
so i don't like that i can't go walk my
dog outside at night without being
scared yeah you know cause i it
apartments they're small yeah everyone
has a small apartment in new york well
most people um not everyone's you greg
but
you have to go out and do stuff but if
you're a woman and you're by yourself
you have to be worried about going out
and doing stuff yeah which so then you
just have to sit at home yeah with your
husband oh god forbid i told you it was
terrible it's going to be over in mere
months
but your point your point is well taken
in the sense that somebody like you or
any of us can move but there are elderly
people here there are poor people that
grew up here that can't go anywhere and
they have to deal with this stuff the
little old lady can't go to the cvs
anymore because none of her stuff's
there or she'll get pushed and killed
tyrus that was more like a statement
than a question yeah cause i'm not
trying to push and kill any old ladies
anytime soon
it's not really cost effective
doesn't get the respect it used to
what are you in for oh got three
grandmas i was like my guy why is why is
it now it is weird that it's more women
and i thought that was always kind of
off limits no it's you know
here's the thing and i've been giving
this a lot of thought because
as you know we we talk we don't really
talk about the show you kind of get a
rundown and you always kind of look for
a funny end of stuff but
the joke is kind of on us yeah and in
your monologue you made a great point
because
we are slowly we they keep talking about
the coup that happened january 6.
there is a coup happening right now to
our american way of life where we are
trying to be turned into a welfare state
where americans only hang out around
their mailbox for their checks
and and that's it
why go to work might be a park we see i
went to get gas this week it was a
hundred bucks to fill it it stopped
which means my truck still wasn't filled
up yeah because it spots out at 100.
yeah now i'm lucky i have a good career
but for
joe and and and who are paying taxes
they're getting killed and you take all
the working away you take you let you
let all the minor criminals out so we're
hearing about murder but i i couldn't
imagine what assault is up but rape is
up all these things and people aren't
reporting because there's no one coming
to the door right so
the coup is not january 6 it is right
now and we need to really make sure that
everyone gets out and vote and does
something to stop what's going to go on
because it is scary and i'm a 6a guy who
owns a
guns and i give zero
if someone messes with me
but not everybody's me yeah
that is true not everybody is you and
they don't attack me yeah they attack
the little old lady yeah because no
one's gonna do anything about it yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else